wenn ihr wie ich food videos liebt dann
ist euch bestimmt alvin chew einen
begriff vielleicht habt ihr schon mal
ein video gesehen eine 100 stunden
lasagne oder 100 stunden cookies genau
solche videos macht alvin und ich liebe
diese videos wirklich die sind für sich
stehende kunstwerke finde ich wirklich
ihr müsst euch anständig verlinkten
channel der nimmt einfach kochen in der
reinsten form gibt der ganzen sache so
viel liebe und zeit wie nur geht und am
ende hatte einen sehr schön anzusehendes
ergebnis und ich habe mich einfach nur
gefragt wie schmeckt das wie schmeckt
eine 100 stunden lasagne das gab nur
einen weg herauszufinden ich habe sie
selbst gemacht ich habe am montag
angefangen und jetzt heute am samstag
essen wir das ding dieses video heute
ist auf jeden fall ganz ganz anders als
was sie sonst auf dem channel sieht und
ich bin gespannt ob es euch gefallen
wird ist es wunderschön anzusehen cops
an eric dafür und eine sache gibt es
noch zu erwähnen und zwar benutzt l wind
gar keine rezepte alles geht nach gefühl
alles ist einfach so dass kunst und das
haben wir nach gemacht viel spaß
[Musik]
lehnt euch zurück leute es geht los
das ist eine weile her dass ich mir so
viel zeit genommen abzukochen und ich
habe es wirklich genossen
[Musik]
ich musste nicht darüber nachdenken zu
unterhalten ich musste keine genauen
zahlen für rezepte wiedergeben sondern
einfach nur kochen
[Musik]
schaut euch diese wunderschönen farben
wir benutzen short ribs für unser sauce
und lassen diese später ganz langsam in
tomatensoße zu kochen
aber da form ist mir sie erstmal
anbraten
[Musik]
so langsam und mit soviel zeit zu kochen
hat irgendwie etwas unfassbar
entspannendes und es fühlt sich einfach
gut an
[Musik]
und wenn die tomatensoße was vom rotwein
bekommt dann darf ich mir auch was
können
[Musik]
ich werde einfach froh dass ich mit dem
kochen etwas gefunden was mir so viel
spaß macht und ich habe ich nur spaß am
kochen am essen sondern ich habe vor
allem spaß am videos machen
[Musik]
die unfassbar gut sie das denn bitte
jetzt schon aus und wir sind gerade am
anfang
[Musik]
und auch bei einer 100 stunden lang
sahen hier muss man zwischendurch
probieren
ab in den kühlschrank für drei tage
[Musik]
wir machen zuerst braune butter und
danach eine mehlschwitze
es war tatsächlich das erste mal das
sich braune butter gemacht habe und ich
kann mich nur soviel sagen die küche
riecht unendlich gut
[Musik]
ich denke gerade wenn man sich so viel
zeit nimmt ist es wichtig dass man
wirklich nur mit frischen und guten
zutaten arbeit
und auch unsere käsesorte dafür eine
nacht in den kühlschrank
[Musik]
frische pasta mit nichts außer eigelb
und mehl
[Musik]
nachdem unsere kleine tastatur ein
bisschen geruht hat können wir sie auch
schon teilen
und anfangen unsere lasagne blätter zu
machen
[Musik]
selbst passt dazu machen finde ich so
ein einfacher und schöner prozess
[Musik]
die fans generell faszinierend wie viele
dinge wie als fertige produkte kennen wo
wir aber teilweise gar nicht wissen wie
sie entstehen und durch das kochen zu
lernen wie man dinge herstellt die man
sonst nur als fertige produkte kennt ist
für mich einfach mit einer der schönsten
sachen daran
[Musik]
jetzt geht die präzisionsarbeit los
schicht für schicht
nudeln fleisch wurst käse soße und
werden
[Musik]
und weil wir uns wirklich wirklich zeit
nehmen wird das ganze noch mal für 24
stunden in den kühlschrank
[Musik]
wenn wir die lassen hier noch ein
letztes mal mit käse bedeckt haben wird
es zeit zum backen
[Musik]
ein wunder
leute ich kann die ganz genau vorstellen
was ihr euch gerade fragt wie schmeckt
das und die kurze antwort ist unfassbar
gut und die lange antwort ist es ist
eine cremigkeit und eine konsistenz die
ihr garantiert noch nicht gegessen weder
seien wirklich also ich habe das selbst
noch nie so vergessen es ist die beste
wahl seine die hier gegessen habt ihr
gemacht habe und es lohnt sich deshalb
habe ich nur sagen wenn ihr mal 100
stunden haben dann macht das ding hat ja
gesehen ist es viele im kühlschrank ist
es viel chillig einfach du also es ist
einfach es zeigt einfach liebe zum
kochen geschmacklich cremigkeit zehn von
zehn fleischig kai 10 von 10 nudeln 10
von 10 insgesamt 1110 gebe ich mir
wirklich ich gebe meine 11 13 dafür es
hat spaß gemacht falls jetzt nach macht
am tag nicht weil ich glaube werde nicht
viele nachmachen und danke fürs zusehen
müssen nicht mal schauen
foto zeit also hier gerade diese scheiß
100 stunden lang sandkamp
x kommen wird es nicht gerade
einsprachen und ich so eine mutter sein
für diese tomaten sauce ist einfach nur
so wirst du so tomaten mutter trinken
oder